mr. Trump who at who is at his Marv
lager resort in Florida is meeting for a
second day with Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a about challenges like North
Korea the talks come as the president
confirms the CIA director met secretly
with North Korea's dictator last week
major Garrett is in West Palm Beach
major good morning good morning the CIA
and the State Department have been
dealing directly with the North Koreans
for some time but talks to create a
summit between President Trump and North
Korean dictator Kim jong-eun have
intensified and here yesterday the
president appeared to enjoy toying with
reporters about what's happening and
what it might achieve we've also started
talking to North Korea directly
president Trump hinted he might have had
direct talks with kim jeong-hoon later
the White House clarified the two had
not spoken how high-level CIA director
and Secretary of State nominee Mike
Pompeo met Kim in North Korea Pompeyo
who is facing a tight committee vote on
his nomination was asked last week about
mr. Trump's plan summoned with Kim that
the president said will be a chance to
resolve the nuclear impasse there is
work being done today in preparation for
the president's proposed meeting with
Kim jong-un the president said five
summit locations were under
consideration the two most likely are a
neutral spot in the demilitarized zone
separating north and south or on a US
Navy vessel off the Korean Peninsula
Kim will meet with South Korean
president moon jae-in next week amid
heightened expectations they could
declare a formal end to the Korean War
mr. Trump endorsed the move they do have
my blessing to discuss the end of the
war as for Russia
the president remains undecided about
new sanctions to punish Moscow for
aiding serious chemical weapons program
on Sunday UN Ambassador nikki Haley said
new sanctions were hours away you will
see that Russian sanctions will be
coming down but the president delayed
that move yesterday chief White House
economic advisor Larry Kudlow said Haley
got out ahead of the curve there might
have been some good moment
confusion about that Haley later told
Fox News quote with all due respect I
don't get confused cut low on the job
less than a month apologized personally
to Haley as lawmakers in both parties
said the White House Syria policy
particularly the aspect dealing with
Russia increasingly looks uncertain and
confused Nora well said major thank you
so much